kabul airport some of them have been
intercepted it comes a day after the u.s
had warned that an attack on the
facility was highly likely
meanwhile on sunday the u.s carried out
a drone strike in kabul targeting
suspected suicide bombers according to
some media reports nine members of one
family including six children were among
the dead american officials say they
were targeting a group they suspected
were planning an attack on the city's
airport let's bring in charlotte bellish
she's live for us in the afghan capital
kabul charlotte so this appears to be a
rocket attack outside the airport what
more can you tell us
well the information we have right now
from a resident who was near to this
vehicle which fired the rockets they
said that five rockets were fired they
left the back of a trunk about four
kilometers west of the airport but with
the trunk facing the airport shooting in
that direction we saw imagery of one
building that was damaged by a rocket
it's unclear if there are actually any
casualties from this but we do know that
the c-ram which is an anti-missile
system was activated i actually woke up
to it this morning at about 6 45 a.m
it's got quite a distinctive sound like
thunder and we understand that that cram
system uh intercepted some of these
rockets that were heading towards the
airport and for a little bit of context
that anti-missile system was only
installed in early july by the former
afghan government and by the americans
because they were worried about a
taliban threat on the airport now of
course the taliban are in control and
they are countering other threats no one
has taken responsibility for this
although it is the uh mo of isil this is
typical of the type of thing they do
this in uh suicide bombings now the
white house has just put out a statement
saying that their operations will
continue uninterrupted i can tell you
that c-17s are still entering and
leaving afghan airspace and they say
until they have to be out by midnight
tomorrow they will continue yeah and
charlotte what more details are emerging
about yesterday's u.s drone strike on
that car and the casualties involved
there
yeah it's still incredibly murky we're
getting very little information other
than that the us has confirmed that they
did do a drone strike and that they say
that they did uh take out suicide
bombers plural that had intended to
launch some type of attack at the
airport yesterday trying to replicate
something like what we saw on thursday
um but yeah it's still it's still very
unclear we understand civilians have
been
potentially killed the latest figures we
had were six civilians killed including
four children although it's still very
hard to figure out uh who has been hurt
in this i must say as well that the us
says that even though they are leaving
tomorrow they still intend to do these
type of drone strikes and operations
they call them uh over the horizon
operations and they say that they intend
to uh still uh focus and target on
counter terrorism uh missions so the
taliban aren't that happy about it they
say we want to be in the loop on this
type of thing and that we should be
consulted before the u.s conducts drone
strikes of this nature and charlotte as
you say the taliban take over the
airport in a day's time so the clock is
ticking what's the latest on the
evacuations now then
well we they're definitely waning
there's far fewer people getting out
than there were the latest numbers i
have is that there's about 250 300 u.s
passport holders that they're still
trying to get out the flights are still
coming and going but far fewer than
there were and it's only us aircraft
that we can see at least on the radar
coming and going the mission very much
is now on getting out the remaining
troops getting out their equipment and
just wrapping up they've only got a very
small portion of the airport that
they're holding now the taliban has
pushed in internally they were just
holding the perimeter now they're
holding the commercial side of the
airport of various uh sides within the
military areas so yeah just the
americans have a small island that
they're protecting and uh their
footprint is certainly shrinking all
right charlotte bill is live for us
today in the afghan capital carl kabul
charlotte thank you for that